we're always in a hurry and here with a
one-pot meal you can make it just 10
minutes please welcome Abby sharp yeah
so we've got some great time-saving
things you've got ten things you want to
tell so I needed move over to this side
so you can do your thing what's the
first thing we need to know so make use
of your time saving appliances yeah my
food processor and I BFFs real life aha
I love this I chop and shred all my
vegetables for the week ahead so that
way it's just grab and go when you get a
crazy Tuesday night you don't need to
schlep out your cutting board and your
knife okay just want to show you how
easy this is with my zucchini here so
just turn it on I'm just gonna finish it
up already so much faster and you just
do a whole batch like that and you can
throw it into your stir fries and your
salads and soups throughout the week
yeah staying with my cheese I also shred
my cheese that way so you can use the
best quality cheese and you don't need
to resort to buying that pre-shredded
stuff which is more expensive but also
not always the best and the best tasting
my other favorite little appliance is my
kettle people don't think about this
they think it's just for making tea but
how many times have you literally stood
in front of the stove waiting for water
to boil cook already cook all right
that's all right it has to go so slowly
watch it so any time I'm steaming
vegetables or making quinoa or rice or
pasta it's so much faster to boil your
water just doing it in your title like
that very odd idea now what about
grocery shopping yeah so take some time
some little shortcuts from the grocery
store don't feel bad about this people
think oh it's gonna cost me so much more
money in the end you'll save a lot of
money not going out for dinner and not
ordering takeout because you couldn't
get a meal on the table so one of my
favorites is triple wash bagged spinach
obviously it's great for you know
throwing in your salads throughout the
week and one of the things I like to do
is make little mason jar salads and
assembly line style for the whole week
ahead right but also just for throwing
in any dishes that you're already making
for dinner because you know pasta sauces
soups smoothies it just adds that
nutrition in there so fast cuz it'll
wilt down in like 30 seconds flat that's
right anytime and you go to prep it it's
ready to go it's ready to go and then
I've got some frozen shrimp as well here
um I always keep a good bag or two of
frozen shrimp
my freezer because there's no proper it
involved get them peel and devein so all
you've really got to do is they follow
them in the fridge overnight and of
course you can get them cooked in which
case it's just you know a rewarming job
but also if you buy them a pre buy them
frozen and raw it just takes like two
minutes in a hot pan or in a grill so
you take another freezer the night
before you put them into refrigerate you
get home and there by and you're ready
to go ready to go okay you know strain
out the extra extra water bay right and
just throw them in a pan and we're good
to go what's your go-to with grains and
stuff like that really low well I'm all
about quinoa of course if I want to do a
big batch ahead of time sure he can't
sure um but couscous is what we're gonna
use today because it's so so for us to
cook it literally you'll see it takes
like five minutes okay so what we're
doing is we're making a 10 minute Greek
shrimp couscous we are yeah I think a
lot of these ingredients so take it away
yeah totally so we're gonna start over
here with a little bit of olive oil in
my pan mm-hmm there we go just get that
going and I'm gonna add in my frozen my
frozen diced onions here so we may was
frozen so i buy them frozen because who
wants to chop onions it's like my least
favorite thing in the world have to do
okay she can get them frozen you know
take that nobody needs to cry over to
cry over onions right I have never
bought from Williams that was a ball Joe
oh that's right it is a great day we're
going for it okay that's a great idea
yeah so
if I can turn this down there we go
there you go so the other thing I like
to do is to prep ahead on the weekend
and it makes little ready to go portions
so I've sliced up my my bell peppers all
ready to go as a healthy snack but I can
also just throw a couple of your bags
into my dinner is just some colors
vitamin E and outline vitamin C colors
nutrition I find when you when you've
got all those vegetables in the fridge
already you know so much for incentivize
to throw more vegetables into Europe
also can add in our zucchini that we've
already sliced with our food processor
throw that in there and the briefing is
wow these sizes is getting a nice little
bit of color in our hands doctor might
be boiling my water in my kettle okay so
you're doing this at the same time
there's no need to take the vegetables
out then add the cold water and we birds
come to a boil it's all happening at the
same you're doing that and you're
boiling that's right all at the same
time so this is gonna get fat just touch
the color going on and the other thing I
like to do is to leave my measuring cups
and spoons already in my containers like
migraines oh cuz if you know you always
have a half a cup of rice or couscous a
few times a week already there just
leave it in there yeah no need to go
looking for the measuring cup while
you're having a crazy crazy Tuesday
night so a couple cup of hot cups of
this is it about a cup and a half squirt
show these guys in here smells good
already know right oh yeah I says why
don't you really want the dinner on the
table fast cuz its myriad okay so I'm
gonna add about a cup and a half worth
of boiling water there we go I'm gonna
turn this off the heat no need to keep
going we're gonna add in the shrimp that
we've already thought out overnight and
the cool thing is that boiling water not
only is it going to cut our couscous but
it's also going to poach our shrimp so
just throw that in there some oregano so
we have that kind of Greek factor going
on a little bit of lemon zest I love the
valta it's slowly dressed not so good
and some cherry tomatoes I love these
because there's no prep work involved
just wash them good to go right right
throw those guys in there and it's off
the heat ready to go I'm just going to
pop my lid on it takes about five
minutes and the couscous will absorb
that water the hot water is going to
poach your shrimp it's all going to come
together and be super delish and it's
gonna look like this and it's gonna look
like this and then we we basically just
add in our spinach couple couple
handfuls of this I know doesn't that
look great well it steps a hearty meal
so good so just give this a nice little
spoonful just gonna get this going and
maybe I'll plate some over here how does
that sound outs got hear me tell me that
over for you so I mean you can just add
in whatever however as much as you'd
like this is looking good oh yeah so a
nice couple of locals doesn't look
magazine worthy doesn't
I just finished it off there's a little
bit of pre crumbled feta cheese because
you know you can get it not crumble but
you know why not take an extra short cut
right and some beautiful lemon wedges
here just finish it off you've got a
balanced healthy meal this took just a
couple minutes are you clearly wrong so
so if you just get these things down in
the weekend always have this out how
about the kettle out you are done you're
pretty much done yeah keep all your
grains like this you know you'll have
your you're measuring cups already i
think i'd make up idea in there if
that's probably the only time i'm gonna
use a measuring except just leave it as
it goes good happy thank you so much
really reaching zero i'm john said want
to take a break we'll be right down